Ми їдемо до детективів!
За сімома дверима, за сімома замками.
29-ти річний керівник одногo з підрозділів
детективів НАБУ,
який називає лише своє ім’я - Тарас,
піднімає для знімальної групи DW
завісу над процесом
викриття корупції у вищих ешелонах влади.
Можна сказати, що це родзинка нашого антикорупційного бюро.
Тут працюють
детективи-криміналісти. Їх в НАБУ
називають «чарівниками»
за вміння знаходити докази на електронних носіях
і пристроях. Саме там
майже завжди залишаються сліди корупції.
Ось ця валіза з дротами до усіх можливих телефонів
часто видає неочікувані,
навіть для підозрюваних, результати.
Вчора в ході дослідження одного з мобільних телефоні
була відновлена видалена
одна переписка між підозрюваним
і його знайомим
щодо отримання хабара.
Підозрювані вдаються до різних хитрощів,
аби знищити інформацію про злочин.
Але в лабораторії НАБУ,
яку оснастили уряди кількох країн ЄС,
можуть відновити, здавалось би,
вже мертві носії.
Жорсткий диск надійшов в НАБУ пошкодженим
з іншого відомства. І там був основний доказ
–відеофіксація отримання хабара
одним з чиновників.
Під час досудовjго слідства
детективи долають чимало перешкод:
це знищення доказів,
тяганина з отриманням інформації з держвідомств
та від експертів, які, наприклад,
мають підтвердити або спростувати
висновки детективів щодо збитків
для держави.
Крім того, самі корупціонери
ретельно «зачищають»
сліди злочинів.
За корупцією в вищих ешелонах влади стоять дуже серйозні сили.
То чим сильніше цейспротив,
тим очевидніше для нас , що
ми вже дуже близько до цілі.
Спротив з боку різних осіб чи відомств
аналітики НАБУ вміють обернути
на свою користь, адже це нові зачіпки
в розслідуванні, нові підозрювані
і нові дані про те, куди могли подітися
гроші з держбюджету.
Ось в цьому випадку мова йде про одне держпідприємство,
яке могло закупити товар
у постачальника напряму,
але зробило це через посередників
за завищеною ціною.
В даній схемі –
це більше 200 млн грв.
За два роки існування
НАБУ викрило злочинів на десятки мільярдів гривень.
До суду скеровано
майже 100 справ. У третині випадків
розгляд ще не розпочався.
У НАБУ вважають це «незавершеним успіхом».
Ми бачимо те, що судді,
які фактично
розглядають
справи
побутової злочинності,
крадіжки, грабежі,
тілесні ушкодження,
вони
досить часто
просто не готові
переключати свій фокус на складну
корупційну схему , в якій потрібно
глибоко розібратися.
За 2 роки вироки через
корупційні злочини отримали лише
18 чиновників, часто це була
угода зі слідством.
Більшість обвинувачених топ-корупціонерів
ще не покарані.
Судовий процес міг би пришвидшити Антикорупційний суд,
який Україна обіцяла своїм партнерам
по ЄС створити.
На це дуже сподіваються і детективи НАБУ.